Kerry lake is now starting to do Trump's
Dirty Work she is pounding Ron DeSantis
we know Kerry lake is desperate to be
Donald Trump's Vice President we know
that Kerry lake is
um someone who is willing to do the
Dirty Work and she's so desperate to be
Trump's VP
she can just taste it she is now trying
out by going on TV and attacking Ron
DeSantis here saying why would Ron
DeSantis even consider running for
president he just was re-elected he
should really be staying in Florida and
the people of Florida just re-elected
him I'm assuming when they re-elected
him they were hoping he'd stay around
for a while so I mean he's I guess he's
in his 40s he's about 10 years younger
than me he's got a long political future
ahead of him and I think he should
respect that the people just voted him
in as governor and serve out that term
for the people of of Florida and then he
could obviously run for president but
this is President Trump's turn
and so oh and there's one more clip we
haven't seen Ron DeSantis on the world
stage yet and and you know some of the
people that are surrounding him are kind
of the type of people that we're pushing
for war that were pushing for the
endless war and yeah so a couple
different things first of all I had to
look that up run to santis is 44 years
old when I look at DeSantis I don't see
a guy who's five years older than me I
see a guy who looks 15 years older than
me he's genuinely 44 years old that's
stunning stuff I mean that's an
incredible incredible thing to realize
and I'm gonna have to process that
probably a little bit later because it's
Bonkers but the most important thing to
understand is that the polling data
supports the strategy of encourage
everybody but Ron DeSantis to run
against Trump
but try to keep Ron DeSantis out of the
race why when you look at Republican
polling DeSantis is the only person who
pulls well in a head-to-head matchup
against Donald Trump trump crushes Nikki
Haley in a head-to-head matchup Trump
really crushes everybody else uh even
people thinking of running who have not
yet announced but
the more people you include in the polls
if you say who would you support if it
was Trump versus Nikki Haley versus Mike
Pompeo versus Mike Pence versus Tim
Scott the more people you include the
better Trump does because all those
other people divide up support except
DeSantis Trump genuinely would benefit
from DeSantis not running and so here is
Carrie Lake trying out for Trump's VP
and certainly willing to do the Dirty
Work will it work to get her that VP
slot back axios report we talked about
yesterday says that indeed Trump is
considering her for his running mate
one of our continued sponsors is ground
news an app and website that Aggregates
local and international news sources to
show you how breaking news is being
reported around the world it has become
a go-to resource for me right now I'm
looking at a story about residents in
Ohio reporting medical symptoms after
the train derailment ground news shows
the headline from The Washington Post
owned by Jeff Bezos says East Palestine
residents should look to agent orange
victims the headline from The Epic Times
a radical right-wing Outlet says Federal
officials enter 500 East Palestine homes
after toxic train crash I also like that
you can sort things by factuality
location and bias check out ground news
for free at Ground dot News slash Pacman
if you find ground news as useful as I
do subscribe for unlimited access the
link is down below
thank you